as details of the mail bomb scare
suspect are still coming in some trump
critics in the media
are trying to blame the president he
spends
most of his time at his rallies
throwing verbal bombs at all the people
that receive these bombs in the mail
there's no ever any acknowledgement of
ownership
um on his part that he's feeling these
flames he said he wants a message of
unity yet he leads rallies
where his ch his um supporters still
chant
lock her up and he calls the press an
enemy of people of course this is going
to happen
of course the president didn't direct
this he's not
technically responsible for this but he
is responsible for
not just allowing the chant cnn sucks at
his rallies
but stoking it making clear that he
likes it
and all you need is one forgive me
crackpot
and looks like one may have emerged
well former president barack obama
speaking just a few moments ago at a
rally in milwaukee he did not
specifically mention this incident or
president trump but did talk about
civility watch
i'm hoping you think it's wrong to hear
people spend years
months vilifying people questioning
their patriotism
calling them enemies of the people and
then suddenly
you're concerned about civility we can
have disagreements
but there has to be a certain code there
has to be certain rules in terms of how
we treat each other and operate
in the public sphere well that seems
interesting since it was just a week or
so ago that hillary clinton said there
shouldn't be civility basically right
now pam
and it's rich because maxine waters is
among the critics and she said
in the last 24 hours that the president
is promoting violence
when as i remember it she was saying
don't let the cabinet rest
don't let him eat a meal at a restaurant
let's go after them go after supporters
of
president trump and that's exactly what
happened to me
um you know i was in a movie theater at
a movie theater
and it was the maxine waters rhetoric
these people were verbatim repeating
the maxine waters talking points
screaming in my face stopping me then
after it happened to me after it
happened to sarah sanders after it
happened to kiersten nielsen
she doubled down she said it again and
now for maxine waters
to continue and blame it on the
president is disgraceful the first thing
president trump did was come out and
condemn these actions
oh come on you know this is unbelievable
even in the middle of the night last
night
president trump is tweeting out that the
press is the one to blame that's
unbelievable
but here's the thing and you the
president is not i what
president's not to blame no i was about
to say i don't think the president can
be directly blamed but you can't ignore
his rhetoric i'm amazed to hear people
who earlier in the week were talking
about this is a false
flag operation it's really the democrats
and i'm talking about prominent
republican voices
and coulter rush limbaugh michael savage
going on in this way
and now he's oh don't don't pay
attention to the president's rhetoric
even though he says
hillary clinton's evil the second
amendment people the gun folks can take
care of hillary
barack obama was tapping me he's a liar
all of this
horrible stuff we're not accustomed to
it in american life
dana worked in the white house ed you've
covered several presidents
you understand that this kind of
rhetoric from the president
is different than anyone else in the
world speaking
he has made that of demeaning and
dehumanizing his political one you had a
chiron on cnn yesterday saying the
president
will not take responsibility right after
essentially inciting
a a bomber there's no evidence that he
incited anyone
oh no what about that van ed i can't did
that incite it oh i think it's clear
that his passions
were aimed specifically at the targets
of trump's rhetoric all right
greg well i it's very hard to take
lectures from democrats
about civility let's take the long view
back okay let's look at decades
let's look at the last two years which
have been which you've called the
president hitler
you've called him racist you've said
he's clinically insane
morally unfit that's just two years
within two years but who has been
stoking anger for
decades uh who's claimed that the
political
is personal meaning they can invade your
life
i don't want lectures from people who
pardoned the faln
a terrorist group who justified the
murder of police officers who allowed
them to flee killers to flee
they said nothing about assassination
theater in central park they said
nothing about the assassination revenge
fantasy in the new york times they said
nothing about kathy griffin they said
nothing about
johnny depp madonna snoop dogg what else
did they do
they fundraised with bill ayers he was
an actual terrorist
his co-terrorists blew themselves up i
don't want lectures from these people
about civil
civility they can shove it up their tush
i'm sorry if that's heated rhetoric
it is heated rhetoric shove it up no i
thought that was very civil i thought
that was push was a better
word than the word i wanted to know what
i mean the reality i wrote a book
wait wait wait wait i wrote a book
called joy of hate five years ago where
i
talked about this this phenomenon of of
of demonization by activists and
politicians
i warned this would happen i wrote 13
chapters on this we talked about it
on this show so i can't take a lecture
from people who ignored me
about this concern i'm just saying that
if you look at charlottesville
if i know
because i think that's the reality and
it's as opposed to
your filtered somebody interrupted me
somebody said you should confront
officials somebody said
we were in dallas earlier this week guy
comes up to me big trump guy right
he's like he wants an autograph and a
picture what does he say to me
he says i'm one of your trolls i'm i'm
attacking you in your new book and all
this stuff and then calls me a vile name
and then asks for a selfie this is this
is not normal behavior that that's awful
that was kill me but that doesn't mean
the president is inciting people dana it
doesn't well here's the thing i
i started going back to june 2015 right
like when this campaign got started i
was super uncomfortable with the
rhetoric always have been
a lot of people said to me that one of
the reasons that president bush's
approval ratings were not what they
could have been
is because i didn't fight back hard
enough with language that would have
been
tougher and it's just it just wasn't in
my nature that's just not how
i'm doing it everybody running for
office right now could admit and they do
admit
that the rhetoric is too heated so
everyone has a personal responsibility
civility is a choice every time you open
your mouth you can decide what you want
to say
but dana you can't be lectured by them
about civility i mean i'm not i don't
feel
i don't you know what i mean by anybody
yeah i mean no i i don't
you know how the left is treated
conservative about president bush i
believe like what they've said about
women conservative women
well god that that's the whole list like
we could go on
this show would never end if we talked
about if we point by point
but you said that and then he said that
and she said that and he said it
wouldn't it would never end
the only last week there was a poll nbc
said 90
of people in america agree that we are
too divided right now all right if 90
of us agree on that we should be able to
actually decide to do something about it
steve scalise's editorial op-ed it's
great we just got some new video
of the suspect down in florida this is
new video that's just coming into our
newsroom
so you can obviously see him being let
in he's handcuffed of course
and we had seen the mug shot earlier
today but this is our first video
actually seeing the suspect briefly
there
as he's taken further into custody juan
i wonder
you've got joe biden the former vice
president thinking about running for
president
he said among other things this week
that he thinks we should lower the
temperature
i covered the 2020 the 2012 campaign
and among other things he was speaking
to a mostly black audience i remember
and he said that mitt romney was going
to put you all back in chains
how did that lower the temperature no i
think that's heated rhetoric but it's
nowhere near it's a great
point why is joe biden lecturing donald
trump nobody is lecturing everybody
i don't think so i think what people are
saying is that we are
incredibly divided as a country and we
have a president a leader
who indulges in the kind of demeaning
dehumanizing rhetoric
that is damaging to our ability to hear
each other to talk to each other
instead we get locked into what greg was
just doing what about his and well you
did this
you've been doing that forever what
about us that's kind of irrelevant i
think that's
important to say that violence is not
i'm sorry speech is not
violence and we have to be able to
separate that like
we have a first amendment in this
country for a reason you might not like
the rhetoric might like
but there are people on the fringe that
might react to certain things from the
left or the right and we know that
happened was to steve scalise
but nobody blamed nobody said that
bernie sanders is to blame for that
exactly or
msnbc that's the same you know what's
interesting is somebody said like oh
it only takes one crackpot right yeah so
are we going to change the way we are a
330 million population to a
to to to do the favor for one crackpot
we better look
and and the other point is everybody's
lying about civil discourse
the people that are saying we need to
tone they are lying i believe you want i
think you feel that way but i don't
think the democrats
the moment they get a chance to screw
you from behind they will they do that
politically
they will say horrible things about you
during campaigns
at least trump does it to your face
that's the most transparent insult you
will ever get
comes from him isn't that healthier what
do you think though about all these
conspiracy theories these false flag
theories coming from leading foolish
conservative voices
it's foolish okay all right all right we
agree